From Texas,
my question is,
how do you reach someone who was maybe a
conspiracy theorist or someone who is a
anti vaccines?
I'm someone who is staunchly,
scientifically,
scientifically illiterate and agree with
them on what a good source of facts is.
Thank you.
So Daniel,
how do I.
How do I recommend reasoning with a
conspiracy theorist?
I'm right now,
the last couple months I've been messing
around with this idea of cognitive
dissonance.
This is to say you have a worldview.
You're presented with evidence that
conflicts with the worldview so you.
You either have to change your
worldview,
which is hard because you've lived your
whole life with it,
or you just dismiss the evidence and
dismissed the authorities that may have
provided the evidence.
The authority can be a person or it
could be a book or shoot me an article
in the new electric Internet computer
machine to so you dismiss the evidence
so that you don't have this discomfort,
this conflict in your mind,
this dissonance,
and that's what I'm working with right
now and apparently the way to overcome
that is to say,
we're all in this together.
Let's learn about this together,
present the conspiracy theorists with
the idea that he or she may be rejecting
evidence because it's just so
uncomfortable that you're in it
together.
We're in it together.
I'm uncomfortable too,
but when it comes to moon landings,
just ask the person and how you would
generate all that paperwork,
the warehouses full of documentation,
but national NASA created a to make
landings on the moon would overwhelm any
anybody trying to do it on the side.
You just,
it just be very difficult to print all
that and just understand it's a process.
Somebody who has a worldview that's
inconsistent with evidence and I may
have some,
uh,
it,
it takes a while for you to turn around,
like the example of palm reading or
astrology.
It's not something people reverse their
ideas about immediately.
It takes,
in my experience,
takes about two years for somebody to
sort of look at palm reading,
look at cold reading or a Tarot card
reading for a while,
and then realized that these Tarot card
readers,
palm readers,
are just taking information that you've
given them,
the clients given them and feeding back
to you.
It takes a long time in the same way
people who,
uh,
who are anti-vaccine,
I think I've just lost sight of the
history.
Vaccines,
you know,
part of the reason I'm able to be here
talking with you is my grandparents did
not die in 1918 during the Spanish flu
when it has estimated 50 million people
died twice as many peoples were killed
in combat,
in World War One died of this disease.
If you go to old cemeteries,
you can see these tombstones of very
young people died of the flu.
So people just lost sight of history and
you can,
we all tend to go,
well,
look at the facts,
change your mind,
but it takes people a couple of years to
change their minds.
So my recommendation,
Daniel,
is stick with it.
You'll get frustrated.
The person will get but present the idea
of cognitive dissonance.
This is my latest idea about a way to
work together to a scientific
understanding.